we're asked to simplify our to the
two-thirds s to the third that whole
thing squared times the square root of
20 R to the fourth s to the fifth this
looks kind of daunting but I think if we
take it step by step it shouldn't be too
bad so first we can look at this first
expression right here where we're taking
this product to the second power
we know that instead we can take each of
these each of the terms in the product
to the second power and then take the
product so this is going to be the same
thing as R to the 2/3 squared times s to
the third squared and now let's look at
this radical over here we have the
square root but that's the exact same
thing as raising something to the
one-half power so this is equal to so
times this part let me do this in a
different color this part right here
that is the same thing as 20 and instead
of just writing 20 let me write 20 is
the product of a perfect square in a non
perfect square so 20 is the same thing
as 4 times 5 that's the 20 part times R
to the 4th times s to the fifth now let
me write s to the 5th also as a product
of a perfect square and a non-perfect
square R to the 4th is obviously a
perfect square it's square root of R
squared let's write s to the fifth in a
similar way so s to the fifth we can
rewrite as s to the fourth times s right
s to the fourth times s to the first
that is s to the fifth and of course all
of this has to be raised to the one-half
power now let's simplify this even more
if we're taking something to the 2/3
power and then to the 2nd power we can
just multiply the exponents so this term
right here we can simplify this as R to
the 4/3 power and just as a bit of
review taking something to the 4/3 power
you can view it as either taking finding
its cube root taking it to the 1/3 power
and then taking its cube root to the 4th
power or you can view it as taking it to
the 4th power and then finding the cube
root of that those are both legitimate
ways of sum being something being raised
to the 4/3 power so you have R to the
4/3 times s to the 3 times 2 times s to
the 6th power
or s to the sixth power and then we
could raise each of these terms right
here to the one-half power so times let
me color code it a little bit times and
we actually wouldn't need the
parentheses once we do that times 4 to
the 1/2 times 4 to the 1/2 times times 5
to the 1/2 that's that term right there
times R to the fourth to the 1/2 R to
the fourth to the 1/2 power times might
run out of colors s to the fourth to the
1/2 power
s to the fourth to the 1/2 power raising
each of these terms to that 1/2 power x
times s to the 1/2 power and there's a
lot of ways we can go with this but the
one thing that might jump out is that
there are some perfect squares here and
we're raising them to the 1/2 power
we're taking their square root so let's
simplify those so this 4 to the 1/2
that's the same thing as 2 we're taking
the principal root of 4 five to the
one-half well we can't take the square
root of that so let's just write that as
the square root of five square root of
five R to the fourth to the 1/2 4 times
1/2 there's two ways you can think about
it 4 times 1/2 is 2 so this is R squared
or you could say the square root of R to
the fourth is R squared so this is R
squared similarly s the square root the
square root of s to the fourth or s to
the fourth to the one-half is also s
squared and then this s to the one-half
let's just write that as the square root
of s square root of s just like that now
let's see what else we can do here so we
have we have let me write these other
terms we have an R to the 4/3 times s to
the sixth times 2 times square root of 5
times R squared times s squared times
the square root of s now a couple of
things we can do here we could combine
these s terms let's do that I should
just write the 2 out front first
so let's write the 2 out front first so
you have 2 times now let's look at these
2's terms over here we have s to the
sixth times s square
and when someone says to simplify it
there's multiple interpretations for it
but we'll just say s to the 6 times s
squared that's s to the 8th right 6 plus
2 times s to the 8th power times now
this one's interesting and we might want
to break it up depending on what we
consider something to what we consider
to be truly simplified we have R to the
4/3 times R squared R to the 4/3 times R
squared R to the 4/3 is the same thing
as R to the 1 and 1/3 that's what 4/3 is
so 1 and 1/3 1 and 1/3 plus 2 is 3 and 1
thirds so we could write this times R to
the 3 and 1/3 and it's a little
consistent over here I'm adding a
fraction over here with the s I kind of
left out the s to the 1/2 from the S is
here but we could play around with it
and all of those would be valid
expression so we've already dealt with
the 2 we've already dealt with these two
S's we've already dealt with these RS
and then you have the square root of 5
times the square root of s and we could
merge them if we want but I won't do it
just yet times the square root of 5
times the square root times the square
root of s now there's two ways we could
do it we might not like having a
fractional exponent here and then we
could break it out or we might want to
take this guy and merge it with the
eighth power because you know that this
is the same thing as s to the one-half
so let's do it both ways so if we wanted
to if we wanted to merge all of the
exponents we could write this as 2 times
s to the 8th times s to the 1/2 so s to
the 8th and s to the 1/2 that would be 2
times s to the 8th I can even write as a
decimal
8.5 right 8 plus this you could imagine
this is s to the 0.5 power so that's 8
point 5 times R to the 3 and 1/3 I'm
kind of mixing notations here that I
have just a decimal notation then I have
a fraction notation mixed number
notation times the square root of 5
times the square root of 5 this is one
simplification I kind of have it in the
fewest terms possible the other
simplification if you don't want to have
these fractional exponents out here you
could write it as I'll do this in a
different color you could write this and
these are all equivalent statements so
it's up to debate what simplified really
means
so you could write this as 2 times s to
the 8th s to the 8th instead of writing
R to the 3 and 1/3 we could write R to
the third R to the third times the cube
root of R which is the same thing as R
to the 1/3 we could write R to the third
times R to the 1/3 our to the 1/3 is the
same thing is the cube root of R and
then you have the square root of these
two guys both of these guys are being
raised to the one-half power so you
could then say times the square root of
5s I like this one a little bit more the
one on the left to me this is really
simplified we've merged all of the bases
you know we are we have these two
numbers here we've merged all the s
terms all the are terms this is a little
bit more complicated you have a cube
root you have separated the S is in the
RS so I would go with this one if
someone really wanted me said hey Sal
simplify it how you like